[Musique]
2020 toute la planète est frappé de
plein fouet par le coronavirus tout non
un continent sont est sorti mieux que
les autres
l'afrique du moins jusqu'à maintenant
près de majorité des pays du continent
avait été peu touché par le virus ne
cumulant parfois que quelques centaines
de victimes
pendant ce temps au canada le virus a
fait plus de vingt mille morts pourquoi
l'afrique at-elle résister si longtemps
au virus
premièrement ses habitants y ont été
moins exposée il y a moins de
déplacements entre l'afrique
il reste du monde contre les autres
continents des tests virologiques ont
aussi démontré que 80 % des africains
infectés par le strass kovy deux noms
ont développé de symptômes
ailleurs dans le monde on estime que
seulement de 20 à 40% des personnes
affectées sont restés à symptomatique
pourquoi cette population at-elle mieux
résister aux infections
une des explications
c'est l'âge à travers la planète plus de
95 % des décès sont survenus chez les
plus de 60 ans au canada près de 25% de
la population a plus de 60 ans tandis
qu'en afrique c'est moins de 10%
chez nous les personnes âgées ont
souvent été contaminées dans des
résidences pour aînés kandic en afrique
les aînés invite généralement avec leurs
familles souvent dans des régions
rurales moins densément peuplées
[Musique]
le continent a tout de même été ravagés
par d'autres épidémies par le passé
comme les mollahs et la polio ce qui a
été un atout pour combattre la coved 19
car dans plusieurs pays des travailleurs
du réseau de la santé ont l'habitude
d'aller de villes en villages ont
vacciné et traiter des populations si
même équipe ont agi rapidement pour
dépister la copie 19 derniers éléments
le climat le corona virus se transmet
plus facilement lorsque la température
se situe entre 5 et 11 degrés celsius
malheureusement la situation est en
train de changer
malgré le nombre d'infections moins
élevés qu'ailleurs les hôpitaux de
nombreux pays africains ont atteint
leurs limites
certains ne parviennent plus à traiter
les patients par manque de personnel et
d'équipement
résultat le taux de mortalité est en
train de grimper en flèche des passants
depuis peu la moyenne mondiale
un triste rappel que tous ne sont pas
égaux face à la pandémie